hi everybody I'm Drew and we're gonna
play a game here called what would I
drew
our first question is how did not come
off too aggressive early on while dating
honestly just come off as aggressive why
not you're an aggressive person or if
you have a very effervescent personality
you should let that shine through I
think we worry too much about how we can
manipulate people into liking us but I
really think the most important question
is well do I like this person so if you
feel aggressive or you know very forward
go for it and if that's too much for
them then they're probably not your
person tanks I'm having an Oprah aha
moment right now because it's so true we
always ask ourselves do they like me and
the question is do I like them and once
you put something through that lens you
worry a lot less about how you're coming
across a date is not a job interview
it's a compatibility Vibe check it is
best to just bring your whole self to
the to the tables where has that been
all our lives our next question is how
do you ask a guy out you simply go up to
him and you say I think you're really
handsome and then I just stop talking
and stare at them and then I walk away
and then they always ask you out or you
can DM them and just say hey do you want
to get a drink sometime it is that
simple I've gotten many a boyfriend that
way it's very rare that men initiate
anything anymore I think it's a
confusing time like nobody knows what to
do anymore in a dating app world so true
when I was younger I never had a problem
asking somebody out or going after it
and I feel like that's how I landed all
my boyfriends too was just by going for
it yeah we're in this kind of in a state
of flux right now with dating yeah all
these new channels I think you have to
flip it and see it as a positive and
think there are no rules anymore if you
feel moved to ask a guy out you can just
do it and if you feel like being corded
in Wood then you know wait till they ask
you out and if they don't
single after a 30-year relationship
where do I start
you start my dear at the beginning and
it's going to be a long journey and it's
probably a little or a lot scary but you
start at the beginning drawing a Line in
the Sand and I'm leaving this past
chapter of my life behind and I'm
starting a new one and I I am in
unchartered territory and I'm going to
take it nice and slow step by step
dipping my toe in at first asking my
support system for help and guidance and
just start reaching out to your support
system and being honest about what you
need and seeking it out and then being
able to receive it is crucial okay what
do you think of people hooking up while
on a break it's the classic Ross and
Rachel or having an open relationship
hey everyone has their own thing an open
relationship wouldn't work for me
personally but you know some people love
it I don't really believe in breaks I
think breaks are just I think they're a
layover to break up sometimes it's for a
good reason like both people are one
person is scared they they're not quite
ready they want to keep one foot in one
foot out but I just I think it's
actually doing a disservice to both
people because then you don't know I
better just break up and hey if you miss
the person in three weeks call them say
I made a massive mistake but a break is
just it's gray and it's Purgatory it's
purgatory and someone always ends up
getting hurt both people have to agree
you there is no such thing as a
one-sided open relationship agreed
agreed communication is definitely key
it's hard to recognize red flags I think
that it's a muscle that you train as you
get older just to to notice the
difference between just an ick and a red
flag and if it's a serious red flag then
you have to take stock of it is this
something that's going to matter to me
down the line or is this just a little
bump in the road and learn to know the
difference yeah if your gut instinct is
telling you something is off it's very
likely that something is off so don't
focus on The Head and the Heart and the
Poetry focus on the fact that your gut
instinct is screaming and listen to it
yeah agreed how to take a risk with love
when you're scared of being hurt again I
think there are so many people in that
boat tanks so many people and it's it's
scary when you've had your heart broken
into pieces I like to think of of it as
heartbreak shows the capacity for the
depths of Your Love So if you have had
heartbreak before it means that your
heart is that big you can love someone
again it's
it's tough you've got to want to fall in
love again to to risk it do not put on
the next person what the person before
did to you yes you have to work on
yourself you're the only thing you can
control and if you broke someone's heart
or had your heart broken do not bring
that into the next relationship that is
baggage that must stay in the past it's
a completely different human being this
time so don't go in with this like oh
it's gonna happen again and don't
project don't project and guess what
happens a self-fulfilling prophecy yeah
tanks you are wise you are smart you are
fun and thank you for dropping your
wisdoms here with us today thank you for
having me thanks if you're wondering
what should yeah here's the lisp again
okay if you're wondering what should you
drew drop a comment and maybe we'll
answer we both have a list we both have
a lisp yeah I love it so for more with
Jinx and myself go to the Drew's news
podcast and uh also just subscribe
[Music]
foreign